Chương xin biểu là chào thôi, đó có cái quý quý khách giả và mong người ở tại là cho giả của sạch của năm không này
em thật sự rất là vinh giữ và rất là cảm động khi mà em có thể
đây là giả đầu tiên trong sự nghiệp, tổn tiên trong sự nghiệp, tổn tiên trong sự nghiệp tổn tiên trong sự nghiệp tổn tiên trong sự nghiệp tổn quyệp
đây cho các bạn thắc mà em sẽ không một nhiều quyền và giữa mái em sẽ luôn nếu mái luôn nóng và
đây không chỉ là sự vi nhận mà có là sự nhất gió, sau sách nhất, đối với em
để cho em luôn có chất gì mà nổ lực hành này
đây, phải càng của gắng hơn, đây cho nổ lực chỉ phủ cũng mang của mình
em là một công rất là ý nghĩa
không có bà dở không có nổng thách nào có thể đi đến được thành công
chỉ có sự kinh trời nổ lực và hành thì bạn thông thì mới giúp những người nghề sĩ trẻ nhêm
có thể, chỉ có nhiều bạn mấy giúp được những người xịt như trẻ nhêm có thể phát hiện con đường này
và em sẽ dừng hôn là sẽ luôn cố gắng là thì bạn thông
để mà không ngờ phải chỉ mắn thông mần như cách những thông tổng quay em đã luôn nổ lực
chỉ cảm hôm nó chất thật cả mọi người
của công em sẽ nữ lời, cảm ơn chân thành tới giờ đình
tới các phát đà lên gôi em
và tới phản thẩy mọi người đã luôn yêu thương và thẻ giỏi em trong suốt hành trình bụ qua
và em chỉ người lời cảm ơn xấu sách nhất tới được việc viên xin, group holding và chí chế ăn trẻ xe 2
để chơi mùa cơ hội để em có thể thế hi mạnh thông mình và đến gần bụ với khách giả hông
lời có cùng em hùng hình xin của người rồi cảm ơn chân thành và xấu sách nhất tới các cậm hồn